hey it's evan
and welcome to my condo uh this is week
one i guess i've just moved in i showed
the condo kind of bear
and i finally moved in and i've moved
some of my stuff from storage it's not
quite complete
but i wanted to give you a quick tour
again with some of my stuff in here
so this is the place and this is my so
we come in the door
just set up a couple chairs here the
bathroom
is pretty much as it is so far the only
thing i added in here is a bar of soap
so i can wash my hands but we don't
really use this bathroom too much
this is my son's room he's still getting
set up in there he
chose that room for himself so let's
move on through here
moving into the kitchen i finally got my
chairs now i was standing up for
almost a week kind of hunched over at
this kitchen counter
trying to do my work so it's great to
have some cherries here to at least sit
down and i do like using a stand-up desk
but this is a little bit too low for me
here at home so i have one at the office
get some fruit in there with a banana
here's the kitchen kind of all cleaned
up
and i got my coffee machine here got my
favorite knife set these guys are fun i
can see like the stabbing man
guy getting hit so you can pull the
knives out there what's in my sink
i was making some rice so i got that in
my sink got the pantry lined up here got
the fridge
if you guys are interested in seeing
what's in my fridge
leave a comment below and uh next week
i'll make a video of what's in my fridge
for you guys moving on let's go into the
master room
so i got my king bed here
kind of all set up my dresser
this was uh fun getting in here but i
love having my king bed tons of space to
be able to stretch out when you're
sleeping side tables
washroom just some stuff put up on the
side trying to keep everything nice and
clean
bar soap here again got the closet in
here
let's move on so then into my living
room
this is great to finally have my couch
and a place to sit
and uh watch some some tv on my laptop
at least for right now
this room is not yet complete so you can
kind of see i've got some mirrors here
and i got my couch i'm missing a tv
i'm missing an entertainment unit i'm
missing a carpet to kind of pull this
room together so i'm probably looking at
like a white shag or something
as i as i get some stuff i'll let you
guys know but
this is uh this is a fun couch
it's a sectional and that last piece
there on the right is an ottoman that
you can pull in and out
to uh make it more comfortable as you're
lying down so this room is is pretty
comfortable but i will change as we get
going
i've got my camera stand set up here so
right now i'm just filming
at home and i use this white wall as my
backdrop i'm gonna probably explore
using a condo a little bit more some of
their rooms but
it's fun and fine for now moving on into
the dining room
you can see my phone is here so usually
when i'm doing my videos this is the
opposite view so i'm standing here
looking out the window looking at the
camera and i've got my phone there
usually in my hand which has the
question that i'm reading so i can
answer you guys i've kind of got an
orange theme you might be able to notice
going through we got the candles here on
the table
and you've got the pillows matching on
the couch and in the kitchen
we've got the uh the chair so orange
orange theme orange and white and browns
the bar here i've got to fill up the bar
i need some wine i need some glasses
pretty empty at the moment but uh
but okay for now at least set up
the favorite part of this place again is
the view
so you can see out here it's great to
wake up to this a corner unit and i can
see all the way down
to downtown toronto and so much sun
comes in in the morning
it's it's really amazing and then the
last part here
is uh my office i don't really use my
home office much yet so
this is the least set up room of all of
them i've got these pillows that i don't
know what to do with yet and a little
bit
of storage and some picture frames i
haven't put up and then in this corner i
just have a chair
my laptop a little pad for my mouse
my ice cappuccino this is what i usually
drink when i'm making
videos for you guys a little bit of
extra caffeine and sugar
to get me going uh so this room will
probably be the last to get done just
because i don't use it
too much got the wall of mirrors hey
guys i don't use it too much
um so we'll see how it goes so that's a
quick tour
let me know what you think if you guys
want to see what's in my fridge
leave a comment below and i'll make a
video for you and i'll keep updating you
as i
add more to the space so you can see
kind of a finished product
thanks guys for watching if you like the
video give it a thumbs up below
you have a question about the condo or
about your business
leave it below i'll make a video
response thank you so much and i'll see
you soon
you